>> Carlos Díaz-Rosillo:
All right, thank you.
Welcome to the 18th Annual
National Book Festival.
My name is Carlos Díaz.
I'm the senior deputy chairman
of the National Endowment
for the Humanities and
I'm thrilled to be here.
Hey.
[ Applause ]
I'm thrilled to be here
and the NEH is thrilled
to be sponsoring this year's
Understanding Our World Stage.
As you all know, an independent
federal grant making agency,
the NEH supports museum
exhibits, documentaries,
and books that bring history
literature, philosophy
and a lot more to the
public, funds the preservation
of historic records,
collections, and objects,
sponsors educational
opportunities for teachers
and students in the humanities,
and underwrites fundamental
research across all disciplines
within the humanities.
And, so I'm here with James
and Deborah Fallows to talk
about their book "Our Towns,
a 100,000-mile Journey
into the Heart of America".
[ Applause ]
Let me give you a
little background.
A little over five years ago,
Jim and Deb posted a message
on the Atlantic Magazine
website.
They asked readers to come to
recommend small towns and cities
across the US that
were experiencing
economic recoveries.
Flooded by responses,
they narrowed the list
to about 30 places which
they proceeded to visit
over the next few years.
These visits were not
just casual drop-ins.
They came, stayed, and
in many cases came back
and stayed again, searching for
what might be called the source
of a new American prosperity.
Their book is the subject
of today's conversation.
No stranger to Washington DC,
Jim worked in the
Carter Administration
as chief speechwriter.
He has been writing for the
Atlantic since the late 1970s,
and he's the author
of over a dozen books.
He has written extensively
on foreign policy, China,
and many issues of
national politics.
He and his wife Deb have
spent many years abroad living
in Japan, Malaysia, and China.
Deb, who is a trained linguist,
is the author of "Dreaming
in Mandarin", an account of her
journey into Chinese language
and culture during
their most recent stays
in Shanghai and Beijing.
So, if you're ready,
we can start now.
>> Deborah Fallows: We're ready.
>> Carlos Díaz-Rosillo:
All right.
[ Applause ]
So, the first -- and by the
way, I'll ask a few questions
and then I'm sure your
questions are going
to be better than my questions.
So, we'll leave a few minutes
for Q and A from the audience
so you can ask them
any questions you want.
Many accounts of American life
have been written, of course,
but yours is the only
one that I've read
where the authors
travel by plane.
You travel in a very
small plane,
couple of seats,
throughout the US.
So, I want to ask you,
what would you say
makes your book unique?
What is the uniqueness
of your book
that will make everybody
rush out and buy the book?
>> Deborah Fallows: Maybe that
we're still married after it.
[ Applause and Laughter ]
>> James Fallows: And,
we've been together
since we were age 18, which is
longer ago for me than for Deb,
but we've been together
all those times.
>> Deborah Fallows: But--
>> James Fallows: So, there --
so first Carlos,
thank you so much.
Thanks to the Library of
Congress, thanks to the NEH,
thanks to the book festival,
thanks to you all
for coming here.
We're really honored to be
back here in our hometown.
We've haven't been
for a long time,
talking about what we've seen
while we've been on the road.
Anybody who has read in
American history and literature,
as you all have, know that the
road trip or the Pirogue trip
or the ox cart trip or the other
kind of trip is a main motif
and schtick for understanding
America.
And, there's a reason for that.
It's a big dispersed country
with a huge extent from side
to side and north to south,
and so there's a good reason
that so many Americans --
sagas Americana or road trips
of one kind or another.
We -- because we had
before we lived in China,
been around the country a fair
amount in our little tiny,
essentially flying car kind
of an airplane, a Sirius SR22,
which has a parachute
for the entire airplane.
Whole different topic
we can get into.
We knew how -- we know both how
interesting the landscape was
as you see it unfold at low
altitude from 2000 feet up,
but also how much of the
country is accessible this way.
So, I think that the one
perspective that's different
in this book is that it's
a low altitude aerial means
of transport and one
counterpart I can think
of is is a marvelous book
called "Flight of Passage"
by Rinker Buck maybe ten
years ago or so about his
and his brother's flight across
the country in a small plane.
But, even more, I think
we were trying to contrast
at this moment in media
and political history how the
US looks at the cellular level
from the bottom up
versus how it looks
when you turn on cable news.
And, so I think that
contrast of a sense
that the US actually is doing
better than most people think
at the city by city and
even state by state level,
that's I think the distinctive
aspect of our message.
>> Deborah Fallows: And, Jim and
I both grew up in small towns
so it was a really natural
move for us to look at smaller
and medium sizes towns.
They were places where we felt
comfortable and had our own kind
of history in how towns work.
So, it was -- it just felt like
a very natural approach for us
to do it that way, and we read
all the accounts, you know?
"Travels with Charlie" and
William Lease Tate Moon and back
to Mark Twain, and
they were a wonderful
and humbling beginning.
And, we also learned some
lessons from them on how
to do it, how to drop into
places and get a good start.
But, also how to stay for
-- we stayed for a while.
I suppose Mark Twain
had to stay for a while
because it took longer to
get places back in the day,
but that was an extremely
enjoyable part of our life
to feel like we got
a sense of the spirit
of the places where we were.
>> Carlos Díaz-Rosillo: So, you
got hundreds of recommendations.
How did you narrow the
list down to 30 cities?
>> James Fallows:
It was a combination
of science and happenstance.
When we started doing
this, we just --
we wanted to go to
a couple of places
where we had little tendrils
of connection like Sioux Falls,
South Dakota, which is a
huge and fascinating place
that I had never been before,
and you'd been there once
at some event at
Augustana College.
So, we thought let's -- there's
lots going on in Sioux Falls.
Let's try that.
We had somebody we knew
in Holland, Michigan.
We had people we knew
in Eastport, Maine,
and we were looking for
regional representation.
We -- each place we went we
sort of changed the focus
of where we might go later on.
We wanted to be not
scientifically sampling,
but sort of crudely
representative of far Northeast,
far Southwest, Great
Plains, Deep South.
And, as time went on we went
to places that were more
and more economically
troubled, like San Bernardino,
which is right next
to where I grew up.
And, a long time in
Mississippi and--
>> Deborah Fallows: Allentown.
>> James Fallows: Allentown
and Erie and western Kansas.
And, so we felt as if we
started out looking at places
that were known for
being successful,
and gravitated towards places
that were earlier on the dealing
with our challenges for--
>> Deborah Fallows: And,
occasionally it was
really opportunistic.
We had been in Greenville,
South Carolina looking
at a lot of things.
But, one thing we wrote about
on a blog along the way was this
amazing governor's school,
which is a public school,
that was focused on the arts
and humanities in Greenville.
And, so we wrote these
kind of glowing reports.
It was an amazing
school, and the next day
in my inbox I got a message
from a teacher in Columbus,
Mississippi who was
at the Mississippi Governor's
School for Math and Science.
And, it was essentially kind
of throwing down the gauntlet,
and said, "You think
that's school is
so great in Greenville.
You have to come and see
ours in Mississippi."
So, it's like, "Okay.
That's it.
That's what we're looking for."
Just the sense of energy
and kind of mission
in the great unknown
of what we would find.
So, we headed off to the
heart of Mississippi.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo: Wow, so
as a non-journalist I'm curious
as to how you go about reporting
it, and capturing the essence
of a town that you haven't in
many cases ever been to before?
>> James Fallows:
I'll say something
about the national media
since we're here in DC,
and there's other national
media people, and I've worked
for The Atlantic
for a long time,
and then just about
human nature.
From the national media point
of view one reason we wanted
to do this project is a
sense of the imbalance
between how a handful of cities
are portrayed, and how the rest
of the US is portrayed.
And, what I mean is that
if you think of New York,
those of us who are
not New Yorkers,
we know what ever
block looks like there
from movies and from TV shows.
Same is true of San Francisco.
It's true of DC, etcetera, but
most of the rest of the country,
the national media show up only
when there's a primary election
or a tornado or a
shooting, or a concept story
on how people are feeling in
Kentucky or whatever as opposed
to dealing with these places
on their own three
dimensional terms.
So, one thing we wanted to do
as Deb said, because we think
of ourselves as small
town people, is just say,
"We're here to ask the
story of Duluth, you know?
What's happening in Duluth
for better or worse?"
Not how Duluth is going
to vote next time.
Not how -- not that sort of
national media narrative.
So, one thing was
approaching them
as if their own city
stories were interesting.
The other is that my
experience in the long years
in journalism is
that people basically
like talking about themselves.
And, they like talking about
their story of their family
and of the company and of their
community and of their hopes.
So, if you just have
open ended questions of,
what's going right here?
What's going wrong here?
What do people care about?
What do people not know?
What do people miss
about your town?
You know, what is
something that we
as short term visitors
are likely to miss?
You'll often get interesting
answers if you go that way,
and that's a -- that
was how it went.
>> Deborah Fallows:
And, on a very nuts
and bolts level usually we would
arrive on a Sunday or a Monday,
and kind of crossing our
fingers saying, you know,
"I hope this works out.
We're committed here
for the week."
And, we would go see what we
fondly call the usual suspects
in town at first to go
together to stop and see
if there was a newspaper.
We'd go to see the editor
of the staff, and if --
we'd try to connect with
somebody in the school system,
somebody with the chamber of
commerce and local government.
Dropping at the library,
because it's
such the heart and
soul of the town.
You could always find out
what's really happening
if you talk to a librarian.
Applause line there.
[ Applause and Laughter ]
And, that was usually
the first day,
and then the second day we would
go in our different directions,
and our kind of different
skill set
or interest of what we followed.
And, round about
Wednesday we'd think,
"There's no way we're
ever going to get
through everything we need
to find in this town."
It was just following
a breadcrumb trail,
and as Jim said people were
extraordinarily generous
in talking with us
about their towns.
We went in with a
very small footprint.
Just -- just, you know,
generally unannounced
with our notebooks and started
to ask things, and we ended
up inside classrooms, you
know, inside people's offices,
at brew pubs, on the
street, at local events
like the sports events or
town concerts or the plays.
We tried to spend as much time
with as many people of all sorts
as we possibly could, and
then we'd often get to the end
of the week and think,
"We'll stay."
or, "We'll come back," because
there just wasn't enough time.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo: I'm
glad you mentioned libraries,
because you talk a lot about
libraries in your book,
and I'm sure all of us here
care deeply about libraries.
I know that all of that
at the NEH care very
much about libraries.
What is about libraries
that struck --
that, yeah, struck you?
>> Deborah Fallows: It
was such a surprised,
and I'm actually embarrassed
that I didn't know
this five years ago,
because I thought
libraries were the same kind
of institution that
I grew up with.
Where you went in kind
of tiptoeing very quietly
and were told to shush,
and find your corner
in the back of the room.
Now I've learned from
being in libraries in just
about every city we covered that
they are the place that fill
in the gaps that is
needed by the town.
Whether it's an education
starting
from preschool skills all the
way up through adult literacy,
or if it's in technology,
providing Wi-Fi access.
I used to work in the Pew
Research Center and know
for a fact that 25 percent
of the country doesn't
have fast Wi-Fi at home.
And, often even -- even
computers, so it's a --
it's the go to place to remain
connected with the world,
and also as civic
and social centers.
Not only for ESL classes,
or how to become a citizen,
but for fun stuff like
do yoga, get a latte.
For very responsive stuff
they're always the institutions
that stay open.
In Ferguson, Missouri
after Hurricane --
the one in New Jersey,
after Hurricane Harvey,
and in Houston they
are the, "We are open.
We will be here for you.
Tell us what you need."
Over the door of the
main library in Columbus,
Ohio it says, "Open to all."
And, that, you know, really hit
home when you go there at 10:00
to 9:00 in the morning and see
the homeless people waiting
to go in to a safe haven.
Or, when you stay there all
day and see the kind of hordes
of people moving in and
out for whatever they do.
So, we became complete
evangelists
for how public libraries
have -- what they've become.
[ Applause ]
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo: Besides
libraries, were there any
of institutions that taught
you something about America
that you didn't know already?
>> James Fallows: Yes.
My equivalent of the embarrassed
to say I didn't know
this before discovery
for Deborah libraries
is community colleges,
and I say that because -- yeah.
[ Applause and Laughter ]
So, we've spent, as
Carlos said, we spent a lot
of our life overseas and
seeing the US from afar,
and from an overseas
perspective even more
than from a domestic
perspective.
You know, the research
universities are of course
so crucial to American
leadership and future economic
and other prospects, etcetera.
And, that is true, but I had
no first hand appreciation
of how crucial community
colleges are right
at this moment of
economic history
and of cultural history
in this way.
We went to a lot of places
where there'd been some kind
of historic economic shock.
In Erie, Pennsylvania the
big GE plant is closing down.
In Allentown, of course
the steel mills have gone
away there.
In south -- Greenville,
South Carolina the textile
industries have gone away,
and there's a -- you know,
a giant list of places
that have been through
those phase shifts
that are a recurring part
of world economic history.
And, you could see that in those
places students whose parents
might have worked
in the big factory,
and who themselves
were not going to work
in the big factory, because
the big factory was gone
and was not going to come back.
The opportunities for those
students, you know, the children
of the big factory workers
actually do exist in welding
and in clean energy
and in construction
and in healthcare
and in robotics.
And, lots of skilled technical
jobs that are the equivalent
of the old factory jobs.
Just they're not in a giant
factory, and there's, you know,
almost any of those fields
they are desperate for people
who have those skills for
relatively good paying jobs.
The community colleges among the
things they do is connect those
students with those
opportunities.
We saw those in a
million places.
I'll just give one
illustration, and I'll give two
for each illustration,
both in the south.
One, it was in coastal Georgia
in Camden County, Georgia,
Saint Mary's in Kingsland.
Their high school there has this
really advanced career technical
training program.
Every high school
student gets a quote,
"Normal" high school
course, and they have AP
and everything else,
but also they have one
of five vocational tracks
they have to go through.
And, they come out with licenses
in welding, or certificates
in nursing or whatever.
So, they come out
qualified for actual jobs.
The other is in the so called
Golden Triangle of Mississippi
of Columbus, West
Point, and Starkville.
The East Mississippi Community
College is training people
who have never worked,
who've been in prison,
who've been on welfare
or whatever,
for these new factory jobs.
They are -- creating
there, so I now think
that community colleges
are the most important part
of the American educational
system right now.
[ Applause ]
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo:
If I may, let me ask you
about another set
of institutions,
cultural institutions.
As the representative of the
NEH I feel I have to ask you
about the health
and the vitality
of our cultural institutions.
How are we doing?
>> James Fallows: So--
[ Laughter ]
So, we saw -- Deb and I are
both sort of philistines,
so we had not paid that
much attention to public art
in general, or the
institutional,
cultural patrimony that you
all are creating in others.
And, we come away being
really impressed by that to.
That the sense of local
patriotism, local place,
local engagement, that comes
from libraries and from museums
and from public places
of all sorts.
I'll again -- I'll give an
illustration from Mississippi U
and maybe one from Duluth.
So, -- for another one, so
in the East Mississippi --
or, Mississippi School
of Math and Sciences
that Deb was mentioning, this
is from a place obviously --
everything about Mississippi
is burdens shaped and seamed
to the legacy of
slavery and race there.
And, this part of Mississippi in
particular was the hospital town
for the Battle of Shiloh, and
they had lots of plantations
around there in the
slavery days.
And, the whole mission of the
Mississippi School of Math
and Sciences, despite its name,
is essentially teaching
the history
and the culture of the region.
They do reenactments of every
stage of the area's history
with a mixed race cast of
the school students from all
across the state
playing plantation owners
and enslaved people and people
during the reconstruction era
and every stage of
the city's history.
And, so it's a crucial part
of that area's identity.
The humanity's formation
they're all getting.
>> Deborah Fallows:
And, two other examples
from opposite ends of the
country, and let me start
by saying that institution
feels like a really big word
when you're in a small town.
So, I would shrink that
down to the local theater
or the local art
gallery or, you know,
the local performing
arts center.
We saw two towns in
particular that seemed
to be recreating
themselves with the core
of being their arts programs.
Their arts' art in
some way or another.
Ajo, Arizona, which is a
small former mining town
in southwest Arizona.
Eastport, Maine which is
far down east as you --
across from Campobello Island.
It's way out there.
In Eastport in particular
everything
in the town is starting
to be organized
around the arts in some way.
The main street redevelopment
of the town, which is anchored
by a former bank
building, which is now --
it's called the Tides
Institute and Museum.
It's all of the history of
the town in museum form.
Everybody's everything from this
old fishing town that's ever
existed in a lovely way.
All along the main street
are galleries and studios,
and there art walks every night,
because everyone in town seems
to be an artist of some sort.
The light, it's about
the light both --
they said in both
of those towns.
In Eastport, Maine, which it
has 1400 people, everybody has
to be part of this, otherwise
the town just won't work.
We went to a performance
one night in the old --
in what's their art center,
it's a civic building,
of The Glass Menagerie.
Three people, they can't
have big productions.
The stage manager was also
the barista in the coffee shop
and the nephrologist
and the clinic,
and she just had purchased
a dog kennel where,
you know, people would go.
Mixed and matched somehow.
The guy taking tickets for
the performance was the editor
of the newspaper.
So, you were really a slacker
if you didn't wear three hats,
and one of them had to be
something about promoting
and sustaining the
arts in that community.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo: Great.
So, you met hundreds
and hundreds of people.
Was there any one person
that you said, "Wow,
everybody should
meet this person,"
and can you describe
this person?
>> Deborah Fallows: Okay.
>> James Fallows: Go you.
>> Deborah Fallows: I'm going
to lead with one person,
and it's a -- there is a
young guy in his mid-30s
in Erie, Pennsylvania.
His name is Ferki Ferati.
It's Ferki -- last
name F-E-R-A-T-I.
Ferki Ferati.
He is a refugee.
He's a -- from--
>> James Fallows: He's
an Albanian Kosovar.
>> Deborah Fallows:
An Albanian Kosovar.
He, blah blah blah,
troubles in the country.
When he was 15 years old
he came with his family,
it was 20 years ago
roughly, to the US,
and a story he has told
I'm sure many times.
I can't tell as well as he
does, but when they were --
ended up in New York
they asked the family,
"Where would you like to go?"
And, they said, "Well, we'd
like to be near New York."
Meaning, New York City,
and they said, "Great,
we've got the place for you.
Erie, Pennsylvania.
It's right next to New York."
[ Laughter ]
And, Ferki has said that was
kind of the greatest thing
that went wrong and
then right in his life,
because he was mentored -- ten
percent of the people in Erie,
Pennsylvania are refugees,
just flat out refugees.
And, they have an amazing
system of how to embrace
and incorporate this
population into the town,
which has been the secret to the
economic success of the town.
Ferki himself, you know,
came as a 15 year old.
He went into a high school.
Then he went to college.
There are four colleges
in Erie, Pennsylvania.
Who knew? We all know now.
He just earned his PhD from --
at the University of
Pittsburgh, I think.
>> James Fallows:
I think so, yeah.
>> Deborah Fallows: In US
studies, and, you know,
if this kid had been born
in the US we would end
up knowing a lot more about him.
He would be -- he is
a player in this town.
He now runs what is the
equivalent of Brookings AEI.
[Inaudible] Institution,
an intellectual
and civic institution in town.
He's gorgeous.
He has a--
[ Laughter ]
Charismatic.
Has a young Russian wife
whom he met on a year abroad.
They have become a core of
the town, and you think,
"This is great, because
it's Ferki.
He's just who he is, and this
is great, because it's America.
And, this who we bring here, and
this is what they can do here,"
so he's my number one.
[ Applause ]
>> James Fallows: So,
further to Deb's point
about the gorgeousness of Ferki.
He points out that he is the
blondest, most blue eyed,
Muslim refugee you're ever going
to see in Erie, Pennsylvania.
So, I've been thinking about
a lot of sort of larger
than life characters we met.
For example, Captain Bob Peacock
of Eastport, Maine who was sort
of this world roving sea
captain who's come back
to try to save the time.
Or, Joe Max Higgins and Brenda
Lathen [assumed spellings]
in Mississippi who've
willing their way to six
or seven billion dollars'
worth of investment.
Or, a guy name Mike
Gallow [assumed spelling]
in San Bernardino who
is a politically very,
very conservative defense
contractor guy who decided
that his mission in life was
to improve the San
Bernardino public schools.
He's now chairman
of the school board
and spends all his
time doing that.
But, I'm going to not talk
about any of those larger
than life characters, and
talk about somebody who has --
I wish people would meet,
because of her relevance
to modern America's future.
This is a woman named
Ashley Swearengin
who has just been timed out
after two terms as the mayor
of Fresno, California.
Those of you who are from
California like me know
that Fresno is the least
stylish part of the state.
As part of the inland
California where I'm from,
this sort of looked down --
looked down by the coast.
Fresno is part of a very
important agricultural region,
but its downtown has been
devastated by [inaudible]
in the way that many
downtowns have been.
And, Ashley Swearengin, in her
two terms as a Republican mayor
of Fresno, which has a
heavily Latino population,
and a lot of poverty in
Fresno, was the center
of this urban redevelopment
effort of --
which has seemed
to be successfully
recasting Fresno as,
number one, a center
of the arts.
Because, the real
estate cost there is
like one-fifth what it would
be a hundred miles away
in the Bay area.
So, they're trying --
they're having arts there.
They're having agricultural,
science, and technology.
They're -- the beginning of
the high speed rail system
for California is there.
Side note, people in LA
and San Francisco said,
"The California high
speed rail is being built
in the middle of nowhere."
So, Fresno said,
"Welcome to nowhere."
You know, "This is
where we are,"
and they're changing their
motto to, "Fresyes from Fresno."
So, I think Ashley Swearengin
who now runs the community
foundation in Fresno is sort
of an illustration of the,
apart from the polarization
of national politics,
practicality you can
find on a local level.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo: Great.
I'm going to read
the next question,
because it has a
quote from your book.
I want to make sure I
get the quote right.
Your book touches on
some hot button issue,
but you're not writing
a political argument
of the usual kind.
In fact, you say, and
this is the quote,
"Overwhelmingly the focus
in successful towns was not an
insoluble national division,
but on practical problems
a community could address.
The more often national
politics came
into local discussions the
worse shape the town was likely
to be in."
Can you elaborate a
little bit on that?
>> James Fallows: Yes.
I will stipulate within this
room or with any gathering
of Americans there's a range
of views on national politics.
And, I will also
stipulate from observation
that there's almost
nothing interesting that any
of us can say to
anybody else on the front
of national politics anymore.
Sort of all grievances, all
concerns, all differences
of perspective, if you
haven't voiced them yourself
or heard them, if you turn
on cable TV, you'll hear them
in the next ten minutes.
And, that's essentially
that national politics has
become a kind of polarized
and difficult ritual
that's disconnected
from a lot of daily life.
Obviously it matters.
Obviously it's of
crucial importance.
Obviously in the saga
of American history national
government have made big,
big switches one way or another,
but the temper of discussion
of national politics
is really difficult.
We found we went to
towns we never, ever,
ever asked people,
"Do you like Obama?
Do you hate Obama?
Do you like Trump?
Do you hate Trump?"
We'd ask them, "What's
happening in this town?
What -- how do you
work with people
from different perspectives?"
And, we found that what you
would like to think to be true
of America, that we all
have our differences,
but you actually can find
areas of discussing them.
And, finding practical
compromised solutions,
and making plans for
20 years from now
that have some chance
of coming true.
That those things still are
largely true at the local level.
[ Laughter ]
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo: Deb, let
me ask you a question if I may.
You're a trained linguist,
so as you were traveling
you were taking notes
on variations in
American speech.
What were you trying
to find out?
>> Deborah Fallows: Yeah, so
one of the questions that was
on my mind when we started
was just how people speak
these days?
Has the -- are there
regionalisms,
or has everything
been flattened?
And, I think that
the answer is yes.
That it's been flattened
in the sense
that we all listen
to the same media.
We all pick up on the same
things, and now I'm going
to ruin your day by
one thing that I heard
that just drives me crazy, and I
promise you're going to hear it,
and it will drive you crazy.
If you listen to any pundits
or any radio shows
people will often begin
with a phrase I heard and
first started noticing
in Sioux Falls, South Dakota.
Let me be honest.
I have to be honest
with you, or honestly.
I'm thinking, "South
Dakota, you have to tell me
that you're going to be honest?
I mean, we know you're
going to be honest."
That -- a version of
that phrase now begins --
I promise you'll hear it
on any kind of nation media
that you turn on or
tune into or listen to.
So, there is that kind
of flattening everywhere.
A really fun thing that we
noticed first in Greenville,
South Carolina, we came to
call the second question.
If you're in a crowd like
this, except maybe it's not --
it's less of a Washington crowd.
They're just people.
[ Laughter ]
Other people.
After the hello, how do you do,
it's -- there is a question.
In Greenville, South
Caroline it's,
"Where do you go to church?"
When we first hear
that I was, "Whoa.
You know, that's
a little personal,
or maybe a little intrusive."
Of course, in DC it's either
some version of what do you do?
Where do you work, and
maybe, where do you live?
New York, same kind of thing.
We started asking in other
places, and if I dare ask,
is there anyone here
from St. Louis?
[ Laughter ]
>> James Fallows: Couple.
>> Deborah Fallows: What--
>> James Fallows: So, St.
Louis, the question is?
>> Deborah Fallows: St.
Louis, what's the question?
[ Inaudible ]
That's it.
Where'd you go to high school?
>> James Fallows: Did
you go to high school?
It's--
[ Applause and Laughter ]
The St. Louis and
Louisville questions are,
where'd you go to high school?
>> Deborah Fallows:
It never fails.
Never met anyone who didn't
say that was the question.
In a version of the where
do you go to church in --
old timers in Chicago
and maybe Boston it's,
what parish are you from?
Even if you don't know --
even if you're not Catholic,
you know, what parish you from?
In Atlanta and Seattle
a lot of new comers.
They're, "Where you from?
Where'd you come from?"
That kind of question.
In Burlington, Vermont, and in
Denver it's, "What do you do,"
but not, "What do
you do for work?"
It's, "What do you
do for -- do you ski?
Do you hike?
Do you," -- that kind of --
that kind of what do you do.
In LA it's, "How'd
you get here?"
Well, I took the ten
to the 405, and then--
[ Laughter ]
In Alaska, you never say, "Where
are you from," because it's full
of people with a bit
of a sketchy past--
[ Laughter ]
And, in New Orleans it's a
version of, "Who's your mama?"
Or, "How's your mama and
them," which, who's your mama,
because you know who your
daddy is from your last name,
but everybody's kind of related
and knows everybody else.
So, that lets you know who
your full ancestral heritage,
so that is alive, and
really fun to hear
from different people
and different places.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo: Let me
ask you one concluding question,
and then we'll open it
up for the audience.
What is the biggest take
away from your book?
What is the one thing -- the
most important thing you learned
from this five year experiment?
>> James Fallows: The
most important thing
that I think I want to try
to convey speaking for myself
with -- in the boring
part of the duo here is
that it really is a
moment of two Americas,
but not in the way you think.
That -- there -- and, by which
that I mean there's the America
that is polarized, bitter,
and seems hopeless no
matter what your national,
political affiliations might be.
And, then there is the rest of
the country that's in the middle
of this renewal,
experimentation, practicality
for all of the problems.
People feel as if
they have some agency.
You know, most places, most of
the time, there are exceptions
and extremes, but the sense
that there is at just the moment
of national polarization,
there's this local level sense
of possibility, and more light
needs to be shed on that.
>> Deborah Fallows:
And, -- yeah.
[ Applause ]
And, I of course agree with
Jim, and we're just at--
>> James Fallows: The
sarcasm there was dripping.
[ Laughter ]
The of course part.
>> Deborah Fallows: Okay.
[ Laughter ]
The -- where were we?
If -- it's about -- the
one thing I was going
to add was cooperative
and collaborative sense
of how people are working
together in these towns.
It's beyond politics.
It's that we can make
stuff happen here.
It's up to us.
We have the authority
and the obligation
and we can individually,
and then better collectively
make an impact that's kind
of beyond our differences.
And, one proof of how deeply
that goes comes from Columbus,
Ohio where there's so
much collaboration going
on that they've shortened the
word collaborate to just collab.
Collab, because it
takes too long, so.
There you go.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo:
All right.
So, if there are any
questions there are a couple
of microphones up here in the
front, and I'll ask that --
for you to please say your
name, where you're from.
And, remember that
questions should be brief,
and end in a question mark.
All right.
>> My name is Lisa.
I'm originally from
Philadelphia, and I now live
in Arlington, and my
question is I know
that you have both
traveled so much in Asia.
And, I was just wondering, and
obviously you've probably went
to a lot of small
towns in China and Asia
and other places
you've traveled in.
If you found any sort of obvious
or significant cultural
differences from all
of your travels, you know,
between Asia or the east
and the small towns you went
to here in America, in term --
you know, in terms
of perspectives?
>> James Fallows:
So, the question's
about small town differences
between Asia and the US.
And, instead of giving
the 20 hour answer
to that I'll give the
two sentence answer
from my perspective, which is
that the US is almost
uniquely positioned in terms
of really powerful small
town possibilities.
In China, there is the famous,
the further away you are
from Beijing the more sort of
chaos and independence you have
at the small town level,
But, it's more getting away
with things as opposed
to sort of the diaspora
of genuine local renewal we
seem to see around the US.
So, then that's the
shortest answer
for a really interesting
question.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo:
Right, up here.
>> Antoine van Agtmael.
Like you I've made
this road trip,
and what has exasperated me
is the collaboration I've seen
locally, and the
lack of it here.
And, I keep thinking
why is that?
Did you find any
answer on your trip?
>> James Fallows: So, the
question from the author
of a wonderful book that
we cite in our books,
Smartest Places on Earth.
Right? Smartest Places is
by Antoine van Agtmael,
is why there's so much
cooperation at the local level
and so little at
the national level?
I think the -- the roots --
the local level cooperation
I think is a cultivated
and developed skill.
You know, that's easier when
you can see the consequences
of your work locally, and
you see the people you're
dealing with.
But, places that are
good at this work at it.
It's not just something
that happens by accident,
and I think that there has been
for various reasons we can get
into in another 30
hour conversation,
of why that has atrophied
so much.
And, sort of deliberately
undermined the national level,
but my hope is that
the next wave
of national politics will be
somebody who has risen up,
or people who've risen up
with this local level culture,
and say, "Look, we're
better than this nationally.
We can do things the way we've
done around the country."
[ Applause ]
>> Hi, this is Andrew
Mingus [assumed spelling]
from outside of New York.
Now I live in DC.
Seems like a large
intention from the book was
to experience places obviously
that you haven't
experienced before,
and convey that to other
people through the book.
Something that really sort
of thing is the debate
for mandatory national
service, and I was wondering
if you thought about that at
all, or fall for or against?
>> James Fallows: So,
could you say the last part
of the question again?
It sort of reverberated.
[Inaudible]?
>> Yeah, the debate for
mandatory national service,
whether that's not -- military
or service or any iteration?
>> So, on the national
service question.
I think it would be
better for the country
if there were more
ways for people both
to serve just for service.
So, it's good for
the person doing it.
It's good for the country, and
it's good in unexpected ways.
For example, when in Ajo,
Arizona we wrote about this team
of sort of the modern
civilian conservation core
who were rebuilding
things in Ajo.
And, they were from
all over the country,
and it was really
changing their lives.
I think the mandatory
part is just not going
to happen in modern America.
So, I would be in favor of ways
to make this much more
attractive, expected,
culturally, financially,
in other ways encouraged
and supported as this is good
for everybody who's doing it,
for the country and for them.
>> Deborah Fallows: And, I think
we saw little versions of that
in many of that towns that --
and, again, take it out of the
politics, or the mandatory-ness
of trying to attract
young people to their tow.
Whether it was through artists
and residents, whether it was
through some kind
of teacher exchange,
or bringing in AmeriCorps
kids, or trying to lure doctors
to their town by paying for part
of their medical school
through the state.
We saw some of this in Wyoming,
but getting to the same answer
from a lot of different
ways was something that --
that so many people
were voicing.
>> Thank you.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo:
Thank you.
Up here.
>> Thank you.
My name is Matt Pricket
[assumed spelling].
I'm from a smaller town
than either of you.
I'm from Homer, Georgia.
You seem to know where that is.
You work for [inaudible] Carter.
>> James Fallows: Yes.
>> Most of the stories you've
told about rejuvenation,
Atlanta, resurgence, you know,
after it burned down,
or whatever.
It was burned down, came back,
and that's been the
story there forever.
The stories you've
shared have been
about those same
kinds of places.
I'm a recovering
alcoholic and drug addict,
and my recovery depended
on hitting a bottom
place and coming back.
I just celebrated three
dozen years clean and sober.
[ Applause ]
I didn't do it.
I couldn't do it by myself.
Anyway, do you think that
that's necessary for the kind
of renewal you're
-- you've seen?
Big cities like LA,
New York, Washington,
I don't think the construction
crane was ever endangered here
during the financial crisis.
So, how do you feel
about where people have
to be before they're
willing to come back?
>> James Fallows: That's another
deep and fascinating question,
and the short would
be we've seen a number
of different paths.
One path is some
communities, like some people,
bottom out and don't recover.
You know, the story of
the US since the time
of the Civil War is a lot
of really small communities
just have gone away,
because some are just too small.
There are some communities that,
as you say, they need a crisis
to get their attention.
San Bernardino has been in
sort of perpetual crisis,
and they are coming back
now and in a slow way.
Erie is in the middle
of doing that right now.
There are other places we
saw that were able to sort
of anticipate their crisis, and
I put Greenville, South Carolina
at the top of that list.
They saw 25 years ago that
textiles, which were most
of their economy were going
to be none of their economy,
which is the case now.
And, they were able to sort of
get ahead of the curve there,
so I think that as with
human beings there are these
different paths.
For some people it's
a healthy tonic.
For some it's too much.
Some people can avoid it.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo: I think
I'm going to have to wrap it up,
so time for one more question.
>> James Fallows: Yeah.
>> Hi, I'm visiting here
from Orlando, Florida,
and I've been a nurse and nurse
practitioner for 40 years,
and I was wondering if you
had an opportunity to talk
to doctors, hospital
administrators, nurses,
in the locations you went?
And, what healthcare
is like out there?
>> James Fallows: I'm
going to talk about --
so, so I'll just answer
briefly and give it to Deb.
So, obviously healthcare is a
very important part both of life
and of the economy in many
of these places, in good ways
and in troubling ways
on budgetary issues.
And, also in drug treatment,
so yes we tried to spend a lot
of time learning about
the healthcare situation.
You can talk maybe about, "Hell,
it was just one illustration."
>> Deborah Fallows: The
rural, very hard word to say,
healthcare situation was
the most dramatic to.
In a town like Ajo there was one
clinic that had to be prepared
for everything from, no
kidding, Ebola outbreaks,
to electricity shortages
or cutoffs.
And, everyone in that town
was worried about what happens
when the one doctor retires,
or the one nurse
practitioner retires?
How are we going to get
somebody else back to that town?
And, it's a serious
issue, because it's --
well, it's the major health
resource for the whole town.
Nearest hospital 80 miles away.
A lot of things like prenatal
care just don't exist.
It -- it -- it's in jeopardy,
and you basically don't live
in that town if you
have some health issues
that you're worried about.
So, we saw people
struggling over it
and working the system
every way they could to try
to get more support for their
clinics and healthcare services.
On the good side we also saw so
many nursing programs where men
and women saw this as
a professional career
that they could access, and
would give them a reliable,
strong, worthy profession.
>> Thank you.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo:
Thank you.
Before concluding I just want
to highlight the fact that Jim
and Deb are going to be signing
copies of their book at 2:30.
Locations are post
throughout the building.
Any concluding thought
before we thank you?
>> James Fallows: We're so
grateful for your attention
and for your wonderful
questions.
For all of your questions,
so thank you.
It's a real honor to be here.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo:
Thank you.
>> Deborah Fallows: Thank you.
>> Carlos Diaz-Rosillo:
Thank you.
[ Applause ]